[Music]
woman of the year olivia rodrigo you're
that girl what i love most about
songwriting is its ability to perfectly
capture how i feel better than anything
i could have said in a conversation
[Music]
yeah olivia we have to agree i want to
say
to all of the young girls out there i am
constantly moved by your vulnerability
it's ladies night in hollywood amen
women
celebrating the women powerhouses that's
my best friend the stars brought the
heat for the billboards women in music
extina her and doji cat taking home
billboard's powerhouse award doja keeps
it real during her acceptance speech
can't wait to break this [ __ ] open and
put the necklace on and
you know that's what girls do and it
looks like extina is all of us when she
spots doja in the photo shoot as normani
graces the carpet she tells et how much
she loves doji cat i've been such a fan
of her for a really really long time i
have a list of people that i want to
collaborate with that i just keep in my
phone and she's been a part of that for
a really really really really long time
and it was a big night for the artist
moms with her putting us right in our
fields while accepting the impact award
the work that you do and that you have
done for me mom i'm trying not to get
emotional billboard's trailblazer phoebe
bridgers walked the red carpet with her
mom and while carol g blew us away with
her performance her reaction to the rule
breaker award was even sweeter i'm happy
happy
super happy in fact she brought the
house down ah yes have your moment
[Applause]